hey welcome to the monitor just getting
right to it this week and what do we
have this week is really the better
question and the answer to that is
threefold or if you are a high school
Latin student tripartite we have this
week the return of the most maybe maybe
the most underrated sitcom actor on
today we have an album that is among my
most anticipated of the year but no
longer anticipated because it is out and
first the return of the Wachowskis
witkowski starship of course andy and
lana wachowski along with tom teicher
have made Cloud Atlas the adaptation of
the structurally bizarre six
intertwining story novel and the
question was how do you adapt the
unadapted a book and the answer
thankfully is pretty damn well the
Wachowskis and Tom tweaker really took
it upon themselves to break down David
Mitchell's novel and build it back
together with special attention paid to
teasing out for the viewer how these six
different storylines which span from the
18th century through to the far-off
future and from continent to continent
how those play out and how those are
interrelated is really a story of kind
of karma and interrelation and
reincarnation thankfully I had I'd read
the book so sitting in the screening I
was I knew it was going on immediately
and it's very easy to follow along I
can't I kept trying to think how would
someone who had not read this book be
doing with this movie and I don't really
have an answer for you so if you have
her the book definitely see the movie
it's really interesting it's visually
sumptuous and at times stark and at
times bleak but really well shot
obviously considering the fire power
behind it conceptually it's also really
interesting obviously they stripped out
some characters that were in the book
and they streamline some things and they
added in some things to make it a little
more Hollywood but when you're taking a
book of this complexity and trying to
distill it down to a two movie length
even if that movie is nearly three hours
you're going to have to do a little
rejiggering that being said
be not being disappointed by the movie
version of a book like that uh is is an
accomplishment that you can only hope
for so if you have Red Cloud Atlas
definitely see cloud atlas if you have
not read cloud atlas I don't know what
to tell you I hesitate to recommend it
only because I think you should read the
book it's great and then see it so read
it fast because you're going to want to
see this on the big screen it is a movie
befitting the Wachowskis love of
grandeur and so it definitely delivers
that so it is out this weekend put it on
your list let's talk about music okay
thank you was my favorite rap album of
last year it was Kendrick Lamar's
section 80 and what is shaping up to be
one of my favorite albums of this year
based solely on this week's new album
why it's kendrick lamar with good kid
maad city after last year's incredible
section 80 he famously signed with dr.
dre and while that is proven to be a bit
of a questionable move for some emerging
rappers it actually it works it works
because it's not dr. dre asking Kendrick
to be someone else it is a Kendrick
Lamar record the there's been two
singles from it which you have probably
heard the recipe with dr. Dre on it and
swimming pools which is maybe the best
hip-hop tracks devoted to alcoholism
that I've ever heard in my life the
thing about Kendrick Lamar is he has a
verbal dexterity that is straight out of
like 90s underground hip-hop and it's
amazing to hear that this is the dude
who is blowing up I mean you expect this
is so much of new music and so many new
rappers come out and there's a
simplicity to it just because that's
what works on radio Kendrick Lamar and
black hippy crew have have fashioned his
ground roots this grassroots movement
based on straight skill and means the
dude is is unbelievable his flow is
malleable he goes over everything with
which of the style to three times in a
song he's not afraid to use funny voices
he's got personality he's got inside
he's got he's got confidence and it all
is put to great effect on his own he
showcases every part of himself he's not
fitting into that thing where you signed
with Dre and Dre wants to make you sound
a certain way this is a Kendrick Lamar
album and they're beasts from dre on it
obviously and he sounds great on them
but it's still kendrick lamar record and
that is the highest praise i could
possibly give it good kid maad city
Kendrick Lamar it is out this week make
sure you listen guarantee this is one of
the best rap records of the year back to
you okay thank you for that let's talk
about TV for a second if you've gleaned
this from from ever watching the monitor
I think that television on cable is way
better than network stuff one of the
rare exceptions to that is the ABC
sitcom happy endings which is back this
week for season three and it boasts some
of the best comic performances on
television seriously I mean you may have
written us off as a friend's rehash but
I promise you that not only the sextet
super tight with their kind of the
rhythms of the dialogue and the jokes
they have together but Damon Wayans Jr
those three words are all you need plays
a guy named Brad and the character but
really more Damon Wayans Jr is up there
with schmidt from new girl as one of my
favorite sitcom characters it's on TV
right now also allies coupe who plays
his wife and casey wilson who was an old
SNL alum and is also on the show are all
hilarious and all fantastic and the show
really hit its stride last year season
one was a short season it might have
been come on during the summer didn't
find it to rhythm last year really hit
and was firing on all cylinders
especially by the end of the season and
they're back in fine form if this is
sure you're not really familiar with
it's a fine time to pick up it's not
like they have so much history that
you're not going to get or the in jokes
that you're not going to get just jump
right in that's one of the nice things
about a network sitcom is they have to
simplify to a degree so there is that
it's also some of the best joke riding
on television today and I say that as a
fan of community so try it won't be
sorry you did okay that is it for the
monitor this week as always in the
intervening days between now and next
week's episode you can email us at the
monitor at wired.com with suggestions
and ideas and criticisms and especially
praising but until next week and the
beginning of the cue for video game
onslaught inspirational catch for
here